GOOD AFTERNOON, EVERYONE. WE
HAVE TWO BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. BEFORE WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATION. LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
HERE WHEN, WHEN? HERE ALVARADO
GALE OF ARTICLE HERE, ARCHULETTA
ASHBY. ASHBY HERE. BECKER BECKER
HERE, DODD. EDMUND LASER NILO
HERE, SMALLWOOD KRAVIS CUEVAS
HERE, WAHAB! WE'LL HAVE HERE,
WILK. WE HAVE A QUORUM. CENTER
NEWMAN. YOU HAVE ONE BILL TODAY.
SENATE BILL 55 TO PROCEED WHEN
READY. THANK YOU, MR CHAIR.
HAPPY NEW YEAR FIRST BILL OF THE
YEAR. THIS IS QUITE AN HONOR.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT SP 552, WHICH PROVIDES
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP TO THE 2017
REVISION, THE CALIFORNIA
SWIMMING POOL ACT. MEASURE WHICH
I CARRIED, WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW BY THEN GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN
. BEFORE I BEGIN, I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF ARE WORKING WITH ME AND MY
STAFF ON THIS BILL AS WELL SHARE
WITH THE COMMITTEE MY INTENTION
TO INTRODUCE AMENDMENTS THAT
WILL ALLOW FOR MANUAL POOL
COVERAGE TO REMAIN ON THE LIST
OF ELIGIBLE POOL SAFETY DEVICES,
ALTHOUGH THAT ASPECT OF THE BILL
FALLS OUTSIDE THIS COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION WOULDN'T MAKE CLEAR
MY COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
WORKING CLOSELY. WITH THE
OPPOSITION DIRECTED ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS IN THAT REGARD,
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH,
DROWNING REMAINS ONE OF THE
LEADING CAUSES OF DEATH FOR
CHILDREN AGED 14 AND YOUNGER,
PARTICULARLY CHILDREN. ONE
THROUGH FOUR WITH ROUGHLY 75% OF
ALL FATAL CHILDHOOD DROWNINGS
OCCURRING AT HOME POOLS OR SPAS
TO HELP BETTER PREVENT SUCH
TRAGEDIES. THE CALIFORNIA
SWIMMING POOL SAFETY ACT OF 1996
REQUIRED RESIDENTIAL POOLS TO BE
INSTALLED WITH AT LEAST ONE ANTI
DROWNING SAFETY DEVICE, SUCH AS
A POOL FENCE, A POOR COVER OR A
BACKYARD DOOR. EXIT ALARM. SP
442 OF 2017 EXPANDED AND
ENHANCED THESE PROTECTIONS BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
REQUIRED SAFETY FEATURES FROM 1
TO 2, AS WELL AS REQUIRING HOME
INSPECTORS TO DOCUMENT FOR NEW
HOMEBUYERS, WHICH, IF ANY SAFETY
DEVICES ARE INSTALLED OR NEEDED.
SINCE IMPLEMENTATION. HOWEVER,
THE LANGUAGE OF SB 442 HAS OFTEN
BEEN MISINTERPRETED TO SUGGEST
THAT HOME INSPECTORS MUST
CONDUCT COMPREHENSIVE SAFETY
TEST THAT ARE FAR BEYOND THEIR
CAPACITY OR THE INTENDED SCOPE
OF THEIR WORK FURTHER AS DRAFTED
THE LANGUAGE OF THE ORIGINAL SP
FOUR FOR TWO INADVERTENTLY
ALLOWED FOR SAFETY DEVICES TO BE
INSTALLED OR COMMAND IN WAYS
THAT DO NOT CREATE THE
REDUNDANCY. THE MEASURES SOUGHT
TO ENSURE SB FIVE. I TWO
ADDRESSES BOTH OF THESE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES FIRST BY
CLARIFYING THE ROLE OF HOME
INSPECTORS, AND THAT IS THE
SUBJECT OF THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING IS SECOND BY CLOSING THE
TWO STEPS SAFETY ADVICE LOOPHOLE
, THEREBY ENSURING THESE LIFE
SAVING FEATURES ARE PROPERLY
EMPLOYED TO MOST EFFECTIVELY
PREVENT CHILDHOOD DESTINY.
INJURIES WITH ME TO TESTIFY
TODAY OR DAVE PACE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA REAL ESTATE
INSPECTION ASSOCIATION AND STEVE
BARROW ON BEHALF OF THE ORIGINAL
SPONSORS OF SB 44 TO THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION. FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH.
I'M RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR
I VOTE TODAY. OKAY, GENTLEMEN,
FEEL FREE TO STEP UP. THIS IS
WELL, YOU CAN YOU CAN TESTIFY
FROM THERE. IF YOU LIKE HER.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO JOIN US IN THE
WORLD THAT'S USED THE TABLE. THE
DOOR IS GATES RIGHT THERE. THIS
IS THE FIRST WE'RE RETURNING TO
THE PROPER USE OF THE TABLE.
THANK YOU, MR CHAIR. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. HE WANTS TO
GO FIRST. UM. SHOULD BE ON MY
NAME IS STEVE BARREL. I AM THE
STATE PROGRAM DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH.
AND I WAS PART OF THE TEAM THAT
SPONSORED THE ORIGINAL POOL
SAFETY ACT BACK IN 1996. WE'RE
FOCUSED ON A WHOLE LOT OF
DIFFERENT KINDS OF UNINTENTIONAL
INJURY ISSUES INVOLVING, UM
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA AND TEENS
AND YOUTH. UM AND THEN WE WERE
THE CO SPONSORS OF SP FOR FOUR
TO STRENGTHEN THAT ACT. UM
THERE'S ALWAYS CHANCES AND WE'RE
REALLY HAPPY THAT THE SENATOR
HAS AS REVIEWED AND HIS STAFF
AND YOUR ANALYSTS HAVE REVIEWED
THE LANGUAGE AND WE'VE COME UP
WITH SOME TECHNICAL UPGRADES TO
THE FACT THAT ARE CLEARLY
TECHNICAL, BUT THEY WILL SAVE
THE LIVES OF CHILDREN. I HAVE
NEVER. I HAVE GOT SIX KIDS. I'VE
NEVER LOST A CHILD TO DROWNING.
BUT I WORKED WITH A LOT OF
FAMILIES THAT HAVE I WAS A
PARAMEDIC, THOUGH, SO I HELD
CHILDREN IN MY ARMS WHILE WE TRY
TO REVIVE THEM, AND SO I'M VERY
IT'S PERSONAL TO ME ABOUT HOW WE
WORK ON THESE THINGS. BUT THIS
BILL, THE. THE DEFINITIONS IN
THIS BILL, CORRECTING THAT YOU
CAN'T PUT THE SAME TWO BARRIERS
ON ONE PLANE WAS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. YOU CAN'T HAVE A DOOR
LATCH AND THE DOOR ALARM ON THE
SAME DOOR THAT THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
MANUAL UH, POOL COVERS WHICH DO
QUALIFY UNDER A STM
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS. IS LEFT
IN PLACE. BUT I'M HERE MOST OF
THE ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY ON THIS,
AND WE'VE WORKED REALLY CLOSE
WITH KOREA, UH, TO MOVE DROWNING
PREVENTION FORWARD ON THE ON ALL
KINDS OF LEVELS. SO THANK YOU,
SIR. MR PACE. UH MY NAME'S DAVE
FACE. I'M A RECENTLY RETIRED
AFTER 30 YEARS AS A REAL ESTATE
INSPECTOR. AND I'M CURRENTLY THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REAL ESTATE INSPECTION
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE SO PLEASED
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH SENATOR
NEWMAN AND STEVE AND HIS GROUP.
WE BELIEVE THAT SB 55 TO PROVIDE
SOME NEEDED CLARIFICATION FOR
HOME INSPECTORS, WHO ARE CHARGED
WITH CONDUCTING POOL SAFETY
FEATURE INSPECTIONS, AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WITH IMPROVED
CLARITY THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE BETTER PICTURE FOR A
POTENTIAL HOME BUYER. AS TO WHAT
IS NEEDED TO PROTECT CHILDREN
AND. FROM THE TRAGEDY OF POOL
DROWNING. IT'S A GOAL AND A
RESULT THAT WE ALL STRIVE FOR,
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION. AND HOPE THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU,
SIR. THANKS FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
NOW LET'S HEAR FROM ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
AND SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL 552
SURE CHAIR REMEMBERS JOHN
NORWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PULLING SPOUSE
ASSOCIATION. PLEASED TO HAVE
WORKED WITH THE SENATOR, AS WELL
AS THE CHILD SAFETY ADVOCATES
AND THE HUB INSPECTORS TO COME
UP WITH CLARIFICATIONS CONTAINED
IN THIS BILL AND WE URGE YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, SIR. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL 552 IN
THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE.
LET'S TURN TO ANY LEAD.
OPPOSITION WITNESSES DO WE HAVE
ANY LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SENATE BILL 552?
SEEING NONE. BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO MEMBERS ON THE DAIS,
REMEMBERS QUESTIONS, COMMENTS.
SENATE-ROOM HUB. CENTRAL HUB
MOVES THE BILL SEEING NO OTHER
HANDS UP CENTER. NO ONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO OH, YES, SIR.
RENEWAL. I GATHER WITHOUT ANY
COMMENTS THAT, UH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING. OFFICIALS HAVE REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION BASED UPON YOUR
AGREEMENT TO AMEND THE BILL TO
ALLOW FOR MANUAL POOL COVERS, DO
I? THAT'S JUST ONE EXCHANGE,
CORRECT? YES. UNDER THEIR ISSUES
THAT WILL HAVE TO BE EXPLORED
DOWN THE LINE AS THEY WOULD LIKE
TO LOOK AT SOME REGULATIONS TO
FURTHER THEIR PART OF, UH, POOL
DROWNING AND THE RIGHT DOWN THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY HAVE FOR
INSPECTING POOLS, BUT ALL THE
MAIN THING THEY WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THAT IT ORIGINALLY
LOOKED LIKE WE WERE TAKING OUT
MANUAL. UM POOL COVERS, AND
THAT'S THAT WASN'T HAD TO BE. IT
WAS A TECHNICAL ERROR GOT
CORRECTED BY YOUR STAFF BY THE
STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE, SO AS
FAR AS WE KNOW, WE'LL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM OUTSIDE OF THE
LEGISLATURE, IF THERE ARE
REGULATORY THINGS THAT WE CAN DO
WITH THEM, UM, FURTHER DROWNING
PREVENTION FROM THEIR
INSPECTION. AND IT'S THIS. THIS
FEELS DOUBLE REFERRED. IT WILL
BE HEARD AGAIN TOMORROW.
ANYTHING ELSE? THANK YOU, SARAH
NEIL ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SEEING NUNS THERE.
NEWMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
STRICTLY AS YOUR ARRIVAL? THERE
IS NO MORE TRAGIC EVENT,
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT'S
THOROUGHLY PREVENTABLE CHILDHOOD
DROWNING, AND SO YOU KNOW,
GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK AND
SUPPORT OF THE SPONSORS. WE WILL
ALWAYS CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION. MAKE SURE THAT WE DO
THIS PROPERLY ASKING FOR YOUR
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU, SIR. THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WAHABI. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON HOUSING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. RUSS I
WENT WHEN I ABARGIL OF ARTICLE
II. ARCHULETTA TÔI ASHBY ASHBY.
I BECKER BECKER I DODD EGGMAN.
BLAZER. NILO HØI SMALLWOOD
KRAVIS SMALLWOOD CREVICE. I
WAHAB WILL HAVE I WILK WILK.
AYE. BILL HAS 10 VOTES WILL HOLD
REAL OPEN FOR ABSENT. THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU, SIR. FILE ADAM,
NUMBER TWO, SENATOR PORTANTINO
ONE BILL SENATE BILL 607.
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR AND MEMBERS. IT'S GOOD
TO SEE EVERYBODY HAPPY NEW YEAR.
UM RECIPE 607 IS THIS SIMPLY HAS
EXCUSE ME, SIMPLY HAS PRESCRIBE
PRESCRIBERS OF CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES CONTAINING AN OPEL
OPIOID TO DISCUSS RISKS AND
DANGERS OF OPIOID AND OPIATE.
OPIOID A DISTRICT ADDITIONAL. I
DON'T KNOW WHY I'M OFF TONGUE
TIED TODAY. ADDICTIONS TO ALL
PATIENTS. EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
A PRESCRIBER TO DISCUSS
SPECIFIED INFORMATION WITH THEIR
PATIENTS, BUT ONLY REQUIRES THEM
TO DO SO WHEN COUNSELING A MINOR
BASICALLY, THIS BILL WOULD
EXTEND THAT CONVERSATION TO ALL
THOSE WHO ARE PRESCRIBED OPIOIDS
. OBVIOUSLY THE CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
SAYS THAT MORE THAN 1 MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE DIED SINCE 1999 FROM
DRUG OVERDOSES CURRENTLY ABOUT
75% OF ALL OVERDOSE, DEATHS AND
BIBLE INVOLVED IN OPIOID, SO
CERTAINLY THIS CONVERSATION
WOULD GO A LONG WAY TO MAKE
PATIENTS WERE AWARE OF WHAT
THEY'RE BEING PRESCRIBED. AND
CREATE MORE SAFE IMPLEMENTATION
OF PRESCRIBED DRUGS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU, SIR. MANY INDIVIDUALS
IN THE HEARING ROOM TODAY WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY AND SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL 607 AND MR CHAIR
RANDY PARK ON BEHALF OF HELEN,
WHICH IS THE MAKERS OF ADVIL. WE
APPRECIATE THIS BILL. WE THINK
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC IS STILL
AROUND, AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO TRY TO ADDRESS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
SENATOR AND THE PHYSICIAN GROUPS
THAT THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WISH TO TESTIFY AND SUPPORT. OF
SENATE BILL 607. NOW LET'S HEAR
FROM ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE, PLEASE STEP FORWARD. UH
GOOD MORNING. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GEORGE STORIES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE. WE DO NOT HAVE OFFICIAL
POSITION. WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO
IT. BUT THE LANGUAGE IN PRINT.
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
AND WE HAVE HAD A COMMITMENT
FROM THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH HIM, AND WE APPRECIATE
THE STRIKING OF SECTION FOUR IN
THE BILL. SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, ANY OTHER OPPOSITION
WITNESSES? JESSICA MORAN OF THE
DENTAL ASSOCIATION, ALSO NOT IN
OPPOSITION. JUST WANT TO ECHO
THE COLLEAGUE. THE COMMENTS MADE
BY COLLEAGUES, THE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, MAN. ANYONE ELSE? BRIAN
SPENCER, MY AFRICAN AMERICAN
COLLEGE JOB G. I N ECHOING THE
COMMENTS FROM THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL ANY OTHER WITNESSES. IN OUR
POSITION OR OTHERWISE TO SENATE
BILL 607. OKAY LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE DAIS, INTERNAL Ó.
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR ROCHE. ILETO
THANK YOU, UM TWO QUESTIONS IN
YOUR TESTIMONY AND ALSO IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. IT INDICATES
REQUIREMENT CURRENTLY TO DISCUSS
. SITUATION WITH MINORS. THERE'S
NO MENTION OF PARENTS. DOES
EXISTING LAW REQUIRE THAT
PARENTS ARE COUNSELED ALONG WITH
A MINOR UNDER EXISTING LAW. I
BELIEVE SO OKAY? WOULD HAVE BEEN
GOOD IF THE ANALYSIS INDICATED
THAT SPECIFICALLY FOR THOSE OF
US THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
CLARIFYING THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
CLARIFYING THAT, TOO, AS THE
BILL GOES THROUGH UM, SECOND
QUESTION IS, THE ANALYSIS
INDICATES THAT. YOU INTEND TO
TAKE AMENDMENTS BUT IN THE
ASSEMBLY CAN YOU TELL US WHAT
THOSE ARE? I'M GOING TO BE
WORKING WITH THE GROUPS TO
FIGURE OUT OUR PATH FORWARD, SO
WE HAVEN'T LANDED ON. WE HAVEN'T
LANDED ON AND WHERE THAT'S GOING
TO BE YET AS YOU HEARD FROM THE,
UH NOT OPPOSITION INDICATION OF
A COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THEM
AND ANYTHING, ANY AGREEMENT YOU
COME TO WILL BE HANDLED AS
AMENDMENTS. OVER AND THAT OTHER
HOUSE CORRECT AND AGAIN, I HAVE
WE HAVE NOT COMMITTED TO COME TO
A COMPLETE AND TOTAL AGREEMENT.
NOT JUST THAT. WE'RE WORKING
TOGETHER, BUT IT WILL BE IN THE
OTHER HOUSE. I'M ALWAYS A BIT
UNCOMFORTABLE. UM TAKING A
POSITION ON THE BILL. WHEN I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT'S GOING TO
END UP LOOKING LIKE UH AND SO
THAT'S THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE
WITH THAT. I APPRECIATE YOU
BEING FORTHRIGHT ABOUT THAT. AND
THE COMMENTS OF THOSE THAT
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS. SO I WAS
GOING TO BE FLIP. I WOULD JUST
SAY SO. THE POINT OF THE BILL IS
TO MAKE YOU UNCOMFORTABLE. YAHOO
THANK YOU. ROGER ROGER AND I GO
WAY BACK. JUST WE DO. LET ME
JUST MAKE CLEAR IF WHEN IT COMES
BACK IF IT CONTAINS ITEMS THAT
ARE WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF
THIS COMMITTEE. AND IT'S
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE VOTED ON
HERE. I CAN PRETTY WELL ASSURE
YOU THAT WE'LL SEE IT AGAIN.
THAT RAISES ANYBODY'S COMFORT
LEVEL. YEAH THIS IS THE
PREROGATIVE OF THE CHAIR. WHEN
THE BILL COMES BACK, THE CHAIR
WILL DECIDE WHETHER THEY WANT TO
HEAR IT IS NOT STILETTO. THANK
YOU, MR CHAIR. UH I THINK IT'S A
GREAT BILL. I'M GOING TO MOVE
THE BILL. THE POINT IS ANYTHING
WE CAN SAVE LIVES. I THINK THAT
DOOR OPENER TO START SAVING
LIVES AS THE BILL BEFORE US.
PRIOR TO YOURS. MY QUESTION ONLY
QUESTION IS WHO WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO SIT WITH THE
PATIENTS WITH THAT BE THE
DOCTOR, ONLY NURSES, SUPERVISOR
NURSES, UH, THE L. C S W S,
PERHAPS. WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO
KICK THAT BALL OF RESPONSIBILITY
TO SAY I'VE GIVEN YOU THE
INFORMATION PRESCRIBER. OKAY SO
IT WOULD BE THE DOCTOR HIMSELF
PRESCRIBER. THAT'S THAT'S THE
INTENT OF THE BILL. AT THIS
POINT HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
BETWEEN THE PRESCRIBER AND THE
PATIENT. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AND NGUYEN COMMENT, MR CHAIR, I,
UM, SENATOR, I JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU. WE'VE DONE SO MANY
TOWN HALLS. WHAT WHEN WE'RE OFF
SESSION IN MY DISTRICT, AND THIS
IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE AND TO
ALLOW PATIENTS TO KNOW THE
INFORMATION. AT LEAST WE ARM
THEM WITH THE INFORMATION
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE DEATHS ARE
OCCURRING WITH ADULTS. THEY'RE
NOT. I MEAN, THEY'RE MINERS ARE
GETTING IT AS WELL. BUT THE
ADULTS RIGHT NOW AREN'T INFORMED
AND SO HAVING GIVEN THEM THE
MORE EDUCATION MORE INFORMATION
HOPEFULLY, WE CAN SAVE LIVES.
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUES WORK ON THIS ISSUE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
YEAH I JUST WANTED TO. YEAH,
JUST ALONG THOSE LINES, AND I
HAD A FRIEND IN THE HOSPITAL
OVER. UM OVER THE BREAK AND THIS
WAS ON THE HE WAS ON THE EAST
COAST. BUT LIKE THEY'RE GIVING
HIM FENTANYL, WHICH IS LIKE A
HEART, YOU KNOW, JUST GIVEN
EVERYTHING THAT'S GONE, IT'S
HARD TO COMPREHEND THAT THAT BUT
YEAH, IT'S STILL USED. BUT YOU
KNOW THE QUESTIONS ARE YOU
GETTING THE PROPER COUNSELING
AND THE PROPER? UM AH, ADVICE.
YOU KNOW TO HOW TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE FEEL DON'T GET ADDICTED.
SO AND AGAIN. I VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT AND CONTINUE
TO WORK IT OUT, OKAY? THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY OTHERS LAST CALL?
SEEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS.
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR CHAIR AND
THANK YOU FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION. THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT SUBJECT, AND WE ALL
HAVE DISTRICTS WHERE WE KNOW YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE, FRIENDS, NEIGHBORS
, NEWSPAPER ACCOUNTS AND PEOPLE
WHO HAVE WHO HAVE LOST THIS
BATTLE FOR A VERY VARIOUS
REASONS AND SO HAVING A
CONVERSATION UPFRONT, ARMING THE
PATIENT WITH INFORMATION. SHOULD
HAVE A BENEFIT. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I MOVE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
ARCHULETTA. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHEN I ALVARADO GIL
ALVARADO GIL I ARCHULETTA TÔI
ASHBY. ASHBY I BECKER BECKER I
DODD DOT I EGGMAN GLASER. NILO
HØI SMALLWOOD KRAVIS AVISHAI
WAHAB. WELL, HAVE I? WILK WILK?
AYE. BILL HAS 11 VOTES WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
YEAH, RIGHT. YOU. LET'S OPEN UP
THE ROLE ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE. IT'S SENATE BILL 552.
CURRENT VOTE IS 10 0. SURE
VOTING I PLEASE CALL THE ROLL,
DODD. DODD. HIGHLIGHT THEM ONE
HIGH DIÆN EGGMAN GLASER. VOTE
NOW IS 11 0 WILL HOLD THEIR OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THERE'S NO
STRUGGLING.
NUMBER ONE. LET'S OPEN UP OPEN
THE ROLE AND FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE. SENATE BILL 552 CURRENT
VOTE IS 11 TO 0 CHAIR VOTING. I
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. EGGMAN
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. FINAL VOTE
12 0, THE MATTER IS OUT WHILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL 607
CURRENT VOTE 11 TO 0 CHAIR
VOTING I PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EGGMAN GLASER GLASER. AYE. FINAL
VOTE 12 0 THAT MATTER IS OUT.
AND THIS CONCLUDES THE SENATE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT HEARING FOR
MONDAY, JANUARY 8.